-JAMES GUNN: Crew get set--
-CREW MEMBER:
Look at the camera, everybody.
GUNN: Crew get set
and three, two, one, go!
♪ (ROCK MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Today, we are doing
the opening credit sequence.
I always have dance sequences
in everything I've ever done.
The actors were great on this.
They all took a lot of time
rehearsing the dance.
JENNIFER HOLLAND:
The song, it posits a question.
And that question is
"Do you wanna taste it?"
♪ Do ya really wanna
Do ya really wanna taste it? ♪
JOHN CENA: We are dancing to
Wig Wam's "Do Ya Wanna Taste It"
It's '80s glam hair band metal.
I don't know if I'd call it
a specific style. Let's call it
"a Peacemaker groove."
CHUKWUDI IWUJI:
Charissa's created
something that's reminiscent
of those old comic books,
when you see the guys go "Pow!"
and they move
in these very angular ways.
A lot of the movement is
actually rooted in modern dance,
combined with maybe
a little bit of street style,
some of the stuff.
Also influenced by
Charlie Chaplin, Buster Keaton.
(LAUGHTER, CLAPPING)
It's a little bit like
if claymation was in human form.
-♪ Devil in disguise ♪
-CHARISSA BARTON:
One, two, three, four.
DANIELLE BROOKS:
It's really cool,
because we're all so different.
That's what's fun.
So, to see this choreography
on many different body types,
and different ages
and ethnicities, is really fun.
GUNN: I'm very excited
to be able to create an opening
that was very, very different
from anything else on TV,
and anything else
in the DC world, for sure.
♪ Throw your dog
The invisible bone ♪
(EAGLY SQUAWKS)
(HEAVY EXHALE)
-GUNN: (LAUGHS) Cut!
-(LAUGHTER)
♪ Do ya really wanna
Do ya really wanna taste it? ♪